what's up fellas it's your boy t ross um
i got a debate topic question for you
guys
um the biggest thing streaming right now
is is squid games and um i'm kind of
curious out of you four
who do you guys think would win or
complete the square games
let me know i kind of personally think
it's going to be brendan because it all
matters when you get down the line to
that squid game and it gets a little
more physical i just don't see
you know theo steve
i think he just celebrated 10 years with
his wife yeah
we don't want to cut that out
she is white she's a wife
she is a snow bunny though
it's like a korean drama series but it's
like hunger games
it's really good
yeah dude arizona or turkey oh that's
florida you have some mitts on them
yeah dude
damn bro what planet is that on brenda
so the first game is red light green
light and they make the instructions
come on you know red light green line
you have to stop or you will be
eliminated so you think eliminating
means you have to leave the field no
they just everybody's getting shot dude
oh damn yeah and then so then you
realize that the games are all lethal
after that
and there's six six
[Laughter]
um they're back towards the contestants
so yeah
green light red light and then when it
turns around it has these um cameras in
its eyeballs and you've ever done styles
there's machine there's guns shooting
the the so it just becomes like it's
like it's like a really
[Laughter]
little okay okay
take it
why does he need two smoothies who are
you yeah we have two smoothies huh
y'all ain't gotta worry about my
smoothie bro
if y'all watch smoothies guess movies
but anyway it's a really good series on
netflix yeah everyone and yeah you
should definitely watch a good one we're
not even allowed to play it's only is it
for who's it for what are you talking
about the movie you guys
um i watched it like with the english
dub over because i can't stand reading
movies but it kills it kind of though it
does yeah no it doesn't kill it but it's
not as good it's not we'll say this
though the first the first few episodes
and this is just a style of like that
korean style yeah very over the top yeah
like the comedy is very like but then it
really like less it really gets serious
i'm gonna wait till they remake and put
matt damon as the lead character i
should do it well you will be waiting a
long time first of all for that what do
you mean a remake of uh you roll for
that eric i'm waiting for matt damon it
doesn't matter why matt damon it's like
really great and over the top you saying
the show is bad the show is i didn't say
it was bad oh you watched it
i'm on episode three i didn't even want
to come here
okay it's not all koreans either there's
like uh other people there's a pakistani
yeah which
is
yeah he's good yeah brandon wouldn't win
check out t ross pockets
theo would win because he's more
conniving yeah
it's like big brother yeah you have to
use your brains too the i don't know
he's like the guy that got the friend
killed in the show
no no no no no yeah he's the he's he's
the only one
the deceiver yeah yeah he's the deceiver
yeah yeah i haven't seen so uh there is
one challenge where it has to do with
but what about this though what i'm
trying to say is uh who would win squid
game baby i think either
why don't you you don't think you'd win
i don't know you'd slip in your own
semen at the starting line i bet you'd
die
i definitely wouldn't win less the
competition is who can like you know
who's the old guy in it though billy
crystal you see billy crystal's
is he rich yeah yeah
pretty crazy man
i don't know who would win
yeah but if it came down to physical
fighting obviously yeah it ain't coming
dude it does in the end it does
oh it does
don't ruin it well that's the end it's
straight it's on everybody's watched it
sorry spoiler alert get your [ __ ]
everybody has been out for hot seconds
[Laughter]
in
okay
[Music]